que ce soit dans les halls d hôtel de
ville sur internet ou les réseaux
sociaux durant trois semaines les élus
de génération terrain ont recueilli les
doléances de leurs administrés une
initiative qui fait suite à leur
rencontre le 7 décembre dernier avec le
président emmanuel macron 2000
contributions ont ainsi été récoltés
dans quinze communes yvelinoise saint
germain en laye de sujets deux
thématiques principales la fiscalité une
opposition on pouvait s'en douter au
rétablissement de diesel et puis une
autre thématique qui a été très très
très importante
la baisse du train de vie de l'état et
la baisse de la dépense publique
l'expression démocratique avec la prise
en compte du vote blanc ou encore les
retraites font également partie des
préoccupations exprimées par les
citoyens des thèmes quelque peu en
décalage avec les thématiques choisies
pour le grand débat national
il était important que les différents
interlocuteurs
nos gouvernants puissent s'imprégner
sans filtre sans ambages sans thématique
particulière de ce que ressentent les
administrés et quelles sont leurs idées
pour la france
intitulé nos idées pour la france le
document regroupant les 2000
contribution a été remis au président de
la république ainsi qu'au premier
ministre et au président du sénat une
semaine avant le coup d'envoi du grand
débat national